[Musique]
est-ce que tu as une princesse tête bien
c'est vrai on brosse mois heureusement
le super prince charmant est de retour
ouais c'est parti l'enregistrement a
commencé continuera jusqu'à la fin
cosmo est un repris de justice c'est
aussi un informateur pour le fbi
on a un acheteur tu t'achètes tout ce
que tu as cannes
des flics si ces mecs le découvre tu es
un homme mort tout seul tu vas avoir une
chance de s'en sortir
je vais te la donner dans quelques
secondes project
mettez vous met en évidence
ce mauvais pour les affaires c'est ainsi
qu'a dit qu'il avait tiré quand le flic
avait pointé s'enflamme que sur toi
tu dois maintenant le prix de ta vie un
wojtek à combien tu évalues ta vie tu
auras ta condition retrouver en prison
alors c'est quelqu'un de réussir à y
faire entrer de la drogue as toi je veux
arrêter vous fait que le général vous
demande un trafic de fentanyl planifié
de l'extérieur pour inonder les prisons
bouclera richard klimek avis si vous en
apporter la preuve
vous serez libre
sais tu retournes à présent tu en
sortiras plus j'ai enquête sur la mort
d'un homme dont j'étais très proche
peut pas laisser son lieutenant
découvrir qu'un informateur du fbi
étaient présents pendant l'assassinât de
l'un des siens vous voulez voir votre
agence affronter le plus gros
département de police du monde
on aime bien la bagarre à quoi vous
pensez
planté le même famille on s'est engagé
auprès de lui on a promis certaines
choses je n'ai pas d'enfant je souffre
d'un tassement s'est un jour il leur
arriver un malheur est ainsi bien vite
j'ai perdu ma parole ma chérie
le faux père
moi je suis le bourdon et je suis là
pour te passer la corde au cou
vous ressortirez pas cette fois
ça a assez duré surprise
[Musique]